[Applause]
all right
all right we're back
okay now we're back on overtime more of
the sausage party we're having today
for the panel texas governor greg abbott
sent bo yeah i read about this sent
buses of migrants to chicago last week
i'll be there tomorrow night uh
prompting worries that a continued
influx will strain chicago's resources
will this force sanctuary cities to
rethink their policies it is an
interesting question for liberals to be
you know like hey let's have open
borders or close to it and then when
they come but it's not in our states and
this texas governor kind of called their
bluff was like well you like immigrants
so much have some of ours
it's
i think it's worth pointing out that the
term sanctuary cities doesn't actually
mean people say we want you illegal
immigrants to come here it's a term that
was not invented but certainly
championed by rudy giuliani in the 90s
it's the idea of if someone is has
committed or has witnessed more likely a
crime in a major city you're going to
see some illegal immigrants there so
what we're saying is we're not going to
share that information with the federal
government to deport people that is the
sanctuary they're talking about is a
sanctuary from federal deportation laws
and we do this because we want illegal
immigrants and everybody to be able to
talk to the cops so republicans have
been dining out on the term sanctuary
cities for a long time even though they
used to support it and republicans in
texas
former governor george bush
as a prime example used to champion
their border with mexico as like we're
different than the pete wilson politics
of california we actually have a lot of
commerce and trade with mexico we like
that i lament that republicans no longer
have that spirit that you used to see in
the bush family and with ronald reagan
too about welcoming immigrants
but that's not really
what this is about is it
it's about
there seems to be some hypocrisy about
walking them but not in my backyard
that's what seems different about this
this is about terminology
it's like how education works in america
you don't see black people in schools
really but yeah they're going to take
all your jobs
you have to be careful
these people are coming where are those
people
all these people that are coming
neighborhoods people stay poor forever
democrat republican
where's all the help
we backed away from that civil rights
movement and ran from it on the right
and left
we have all these geniuses where's the
lower class economic infrastructure that
brings blood to fingers and toes
oh your finger too bad this is only for
the heart but we're good with
terminology
any type of fake term a sanctuary city
it sounds good nobody knows even what
that is
then then the expert tells you what it
is and you're going okay
that's good you know i was we don't want
them here back east recently i
first we landed in newark and drove
through i never drove through newark and
then we were heading toward the hotel in
new york so we drove through newark and
then we drove up
like madison avenue
and it was like talk about
two different
worlds where's the economic
infrastructure for lower class people
from all the geniuses who come up with
systems
my question is like
i i so understand the cynicism of people
because it's what you just said about
democrat republican yes i mean it's b it
doesn't it doesn't seem to change no
matter who's in office i i sort of
understand why people just want to break
[ __ ] stealing money is the only thing
that remains
and the thing we have to do is not
confuse corruption with the systems that
are corrupted it's expensive well i
don't like religion because priests do
this so that's not the religion that's
doing it when people first started
taking photographs it was always of
naked people
so people were against photography oh we
can't have this photography
it's not the photography
so we have to we have to it takes a lot
of integrity to have a democracy and
we're very short on that
um
scott this is tick-tock an existential
threat to tick-tock
to american privacy and security should
the media be paying more attention to
this i should be paying more attention
to this i somebody told me recently if
you only
were aware of tick tock what it was a
few years ago which i am only a few
years ago it's really changed and
there's something for everyone now it's
like vegas
something for the whole family right but
i don't know i'm
it's my new project when i get off yeah
we're going to get into tick-tock
if you believe as i do that there is no
separation between the ccp and a chinese
company who can disappear a ceo for four
weeks if you believe that the ccp has a
vested interest you talk about the
communist party in china okay and if you
believe there's the ccp has a vested
interest in diminishing our standing
globally
and then you also acknowledge that
people under the age of 18 are spending
more time on tick tock than their
spending on every streaming network
combined
are we comfortable are we down with an
organization that wants to undermine
america
controlling the media our children see
it should be banned full stop whoa
[Applause]
that's going to be hard do you want you
do you look at tick tock marcellus
i don't i can't even see it i can't see
the icons to get on stuff
no but i but you know of course i have
kids and everybody is on tick-tock right
i don't i don't uh
you know i don't look at these
governments that way we're corrupt we do
corrupt things we need to get ourselves
together that's my thought as an
american and also
okay the chinese they're chinese chinese
chinese the chinese are here they get an
education they're doing what everybody's
doing they have i got lost in china i i
got off a plane in china once out of
fear yeah and i said i'm gonna take the
train to the next place
man that's a big country
you don't understand i told you you're
not there
no i had to fly to china i couldn't walk
couldn't swim
you could take a boat it could make a
slow motion
but when you get out in the country of
china it's very different from the
country of america
man it's huge and there are plenty of
people who are in a type of
semi-slavery in china yes we're not
talking about them man the evil chinese
are doing this in tic-tac they're taking
our information we're taking our own
information
we're providing them with all the
ammunition they need but right now you
have young people who believe that
socialism is better than capitalism and
that is just wrong and the reason why
they believe that is because i believe
we've provided them with a lot of
fodder you have a lot of content that is
very pro-america a lot of the stuff you
talk about reflects us in a positive
light a lot of the stuff you talk about
reflects some of the issues and problems
we have here i believe the ccp would be
stupid not to put their thumb on the
scale of content that makes us look bad
such that young people grow up and think
capitalism isn't working that our
elections have been weaponized and
there's some truth to all of that but
the chinese who i think are very smart
have said twitter facebook meta now
we're going to keep that [ __ ] out but
it's good for you
no full stop they're out this is an
existential threat for nationals
speaking of stuff that's
not good for us
or anybody they seem to have this
lockdown policy yeah the chinese now
this zero tolerance policy with kovid
let me ask you gentlemen this
why it's an outlier in the world nobody
else is doing this everybody else has
come to the
finally i think the sane realization
that covert yes it's it's something it's
not good but it's mostly a disease of
the elderly even bill gates said that
like the flu it's more benign than it
was at the beginning we have vaccines
now blah blah blah we just learned to
live with it chinese have this zero
tolerance policy
absolute they lock down cities one
person gets it everybody has to like
stay in the building for two weeks it's
insane are they doing this because one
they know something about covert we
don't
oh
there's some votes for that
or are they just so in love with their
surveillance state
that they
i think that they they know they can
what do you think
yeah i i think it's it's why does the
dog lick itself it's because he can um
an authoritarian
[Applause]
right uh an authoritarian match
government is going to do
authoritarianism because it can and also
xi jinping has staked a lot of his
immediate political future on that i
know that sounds crazy like why would we
even think about a chinese dictator but
he's about ready to
go for a kind of an unprecedented third
term he's got his 20th anniversary
congress coming up in the fall and he
staked the whole reputation of the
country on this policy to say
look all these other places uh they've
had bad policies and people are dying
and they have strife we can do zero
covid because we can um but also that
shows that the communist system no one
can they must
when it was more lethal and less
infectious there was some logic and some
calculus to its lockdown
now that it is less lethal and more
contagious a total lockdown just doesn't
make any sense right
and so it's a it's the correct question
why are they doing this because it's
hurting their economy right uh so
it's and we have the same issue here one
thing we didn't do and i'm bridging
topics so we didn't do the right
calculus on schools right we didn't do
the right risk assessment there they
should have been kept open probably
longer now looking back looking back on
china
i think they're going to look back and
regret this total lockdown because
everyone gets their turn to the woodshed
when it comes to covet what was the what
was the crowds like in china great
right the difference between china is in
here is even though people have
not a great relationship to jazz they
don't really understand necessarily
things about it you see grandparents
parents and kids
and when you do education you see
more than one generation
so we have to understand kind of what
the difference is but also authoritarian
people let's not even go to regimes they
like telling you no
it can be somebody who needs an idea the
backstage no
right so
i'm telling you because they because
they have the ability to tell you know
and they like to tell you no and the
question for us i think to go back to
what you which was
i understand your point but there are
many stress tests for democracy now and
the stress test is does a democracy work
sometimes we have to be we have to have
governmental interaction we have to be
authoritarian
but we're along the way in this process
we can't we don't have enough uh ability
to deal with our people and with our
freedoms and all to where we have
absolutely no control over over our
communities our families our local
governments nothing we need to be like
these people in this instance because we
we believe in democracy we believe in
choice but not when it comes to
controlling our kids we have so much
pornography in front of our kids it
ain't coming from the chinese
and i teach our kids when i asked my
students what is the biggest difference
between my generation and yours man i
thought they were going to say man y'all
played on these kind of chords and you
were doing this and one kid said
pornography
the next one said yeah porn i could not
agree more
are the chinese the ones who put in the
pornography you know no in fact tick
tock is is quite the opposite i mean you
can't get away with anything on tick
tock it's squeaky clean and in that i'm
not i'm not trying to counterstate you
because uh my as a jazz musician my
philosophy is very different i think if
you look at the four of us here it's
exponential power and experience and
sharing the space and respecting what
you say
it's easier to get a get a line to
attack you and be and be and act like
there's only one point of view there are
many ways to look at things and all of
them can be accurate depending on which
way you look i'm looking at you i don't
know what's going on over here over here
i don't even know what he's doing i only
know what you're doing
and i can be fooled into thinking
i can't even see it i'm right here but
you know
there's a lot going on so
you know when you i understand your
passion with that point
and i'm not a fan of all this kind of
social media and pornography and all
stuff the way the ads are saying my
daughter was showing me things another
day how they sell vaping on tick tock
yes here's here's something that came up
for this to get you to vape with a
cartoon yeah and i mean you know no no i
don't like all of that but we need to be
able to have the type of discipline but
as a people who ever told you this about
porn is on to something and that's
apropos our discussion about men
one reason why they're in crisis i mean
when i was a kid the you know if you
found out
if you found one if you were lucky right
a playboy right now we all tried like we
all found grandpa's like basements right
and we all found the little newsstand
out in front of paul's liquor but it was
it was so benign i mean
i remember when when they went through a
whole thing about showing pubic hair
that would the hefner was going to lose
the general motors and ford accounts if
they showed pubic hair and playboy and
now a ten-year-old can see bukaki on his
phone
engaged
we're engaged in the largest
unsupervised experiment of young men in
history and it's porn right and the
problem beyond creating unreasonable
expectations around what it means to be
in a relationship with a woman
it quite frankly takes your mojo to get
out of the house and meet someone right
develop the skills to actually have your
own sex it takes that away right so
stop the porn get out make your own bad
porn
yeah
all right
let's end it there thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen make your own bad
porn
i'm so glad you stayed thank you
you